14 years after the 86th and final
episode of the landmark hbo mob series
the sopranos the franchise is back with
the prequel the many saints of newark
here are a few small details in the film
that viewers may have missed
fans should pay close attention to the
voice of the person who provides the
opening narration of the many saints of
newark if that voice sounds familiar
there's a very good reason it's michael
imperioli the actor who played
christopher multusanti and the only
original member of the sopranos cast to
be involved in the prequel the character
is speaking from beyond the grave as the
opening shot in the film sweeps over
tombstones in a graveyard until it lands
on christopher's headstone the narrator
goes on to recount how his mentor tony
soprano would go on to murder him for
those who need a brutal reminder of how
things went down you can revisit the
tragic scene when tony chokes
christopher to death instead of calling
following their car accident in kennedy
and heidi which is the 18th episode of
the sopranos season six
in one ironic scene dickie multisanti
introduces baby christopher during a
family dinner attended by tony given the
close relationship dickie has with tony
he tries to hand off his new baby
christopher to his young protege and the
infant responds with a crying fit in
front of his future mentor in a subtle
bit of foreshadowing of christopher's
untimely death at tony's hands in the
sopranos the young tony responds to the
crying infant by saying it's like i
scare him or something after that an
elderly dinner guest responds with this
bit of wisdom
some babies when they come into the
world know all kinds of things from the
other side
it's a sobering observation to
contemplate the next time you encounter
a colicky baby
the sopranos was never afraid of being
meta when it came to references to
classic mob movies including several
tips of the cap to francis ford
coppola's godfather trilogy and martin
scorsese's goodfellas scorsese seemingly
appears in a cameo in 46 long the second
episode of season 1 although the famed
director is actually being played by
actor anthony caso the biggest nod to
goodfellas throughout the series though
is the casting of lorraine bronco as
tony's therapist dr jennifer melfi in
goodfellas broncos stars as karen hill
the long-suffering wife of real-life
mobster henry hill played by ray liotta
among the impressive ensemble cast of
the many saints of newark is leota who
stars as dickie multisanti's fiery
father hollywood dick moltasanti while
leota's appearance is far from a
bonafide goodfellas reunion with bronco
it rather serves as an appropriate
bookend to bronco's pivotal role in the
sopranos
long-time bruce springsteen guitarist
steven van zandt starred as silvio dante
in the sopranos and it was obvious from
the pilot that he was sporting a mega
toupee but who was going to have guts to
call him out on it after all he was
tony's conciliare and best buddy even so
those fans longing for official
confirmation of silvio's balding noggin
finally get a look at it in the many
saints of newark played by john magaro
who earlier this year played the young
version of harvey keitel portrayed
gangster meyer lansky in the biopic
lansky silvio and his comb-over
hairstyle appear in the film as well as
scenes where he's wearing a bouffant
hairpiece to top things off there's a
hilarious scene in the film that shows
the early failings of silvio's toupee
presumably the technique that held
silvio's hairdo together in the sopranos
advanced quite a bit since the early 70s
to prevent any embarrassing moments that
still doesn't take away from the comb
over and toupee scenes and the many
saints of newark which provide amusing
homages to silvio's larger-than-life
mane in the series
while vera farmiga's version of the
young olivia soprano finds her in the
early phases of the character who would
become the monstrous matriarch played by
the late nancy marchand and the sopranos
david chase apparently couldn't resist
throwing in the character's signature
line in the many saints of newark
oh
boy you
given some of the strife livia
encounters in the many saints of newark
it's no wonder olivia grew bitter as she
got older and had zero patience for
crybabies especially given how she
endured her husband johnny boy's
reckless and violent behavior when
farmiga delivers the classic line in the
many saints of newark it's naturally
during an argument with the iteration of
tony played by michael gandolfini
farmiga clearly studied marchand's
mocking delivery as her oh poor you is
so spot on that it feels like it was
directly lifted from the actor's
dialogue in the sopranos sound archives
while the many saints of newark includes
younger versions of sopranos characters
fans almost got to see an original cast
member of the sopranos in the film in
the weeks leading up to the release of
the many saints of newark director alan
taylor revealed that edie falco shot a
scene as carmela for the film but it
ended up on the cutting room floor still
a character who appears to be tony's
future wife is featured briefly in the
many scenes of newark and can even be
seen at the beginning of the film's
first trailer in the scene tony is
calling dickie maltesanti from a
payphone booth to ask his mentor to
purchase him some beer for a party one
of tony's two friends standing by is a
blonde highschooler who he later
addresses as carmela as any sopranos fan
could tell you tony and carmela go on to
marry but there's no real indication in
the scene that the teens are a couple
yet
without divulging who the victim is
there's a funeral scene in the many
saints of newark and among the mourners
is a distinctive looking individual that
sopranos fans will recognize as series
creator david chase while chase has
predominantly been a writer and producer
throughout his career and taken a few
turns as a director including the
sopranos pilot he also popped up in
numerous brief cameos in the sopranos
basically chase has taken the alfred
hitchcock approach to his cameos as the
famed mystery director would mostly only
appear in subtle walkthroughs in his
films not nearly as prolific as the
master of suspense in the cameo realm
chase only turned up in three sopranos
episodes during the series run in 2000
2004 and 2006 in which he was
nondescriptly billed respectively as
italian man man when he was just a voice
on the phone and airline passenger
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the sopranos are coming soon subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
you